JISHNU DAS: I'm Jishnu Das, and I'm
a researcher here at the World Bank.
The World Bank is a multilateral
financial institution.
What that means is it's a
group of different countries
who got together and said, one way we
can help fight poverty around the world
is to pool our money together
and either lend or give grants
to poorer countries on various
programs and various ways of helping
them to improve the living standards
of the people in those countries.
Our role is always to represent
people, particularly poor people
in these countries, and talk a lot
about what their experience is,
what the kind of problems
they face are, and what
are the kind of programs that
can help improve their lives.
I work mostly on health and
education, and I love the work I do.
I think the part that I most
enjoy is actually learning
from the populations we work with.
In 1998, I actually set up a clinic
with my brother, who's a cardiologist,
in a mountain village in India.
And I think one of the things
that we were very surprised by
was there were many, many health care
providers around, which kind of went
against this idea that the biggest
problem in low-income countries
is a shortage of health care providers.
Let's always keep in mind that there's
enormous variation across the world.
And I think that definitely
parts of sub-Saharan Africa,
for instance, where access is
an issue, particularly they're
talking about the belt of
the Sahara in western Africa,
so Chad, Togo, Benin, Niger, you
know, Burkina Faso, I think, access
is a huge problem.
But for a lot of the
other world, it's not.
So if you think about
India, the average village
has about n health care providers in it.
Then you say, well,
look, it's not access
we are talking about because after all,
who are these health care providers.
What we are talking about access is
guys who are fully qualified doctors.
Then you say, well, of
course, access is an issue
because look, fully qualified doctors,
there's only one every five villages.
Then they come back to
you and say, don't you
have the idea that a fully qualified
doctor is a high quality doctor.
And the moment you say, yes, I have
you because then I can say, well,
do you have any evidence for that?
And that's when I bring forth
to say, a fully qualified doctor
in the public sector is
worse than the guy who's
not qualified in the private sector.
So I think people always have in the
back of their mind access with quality.
But the mistake that's
being made time and again
is they equate
qualifications with quality.
And once we can break that mental
model, I think we're through.
I think we are all talking
about the same thing.
It is just semantics.